my name is Lizzie and her doctor I'm
originally from Pendleton I'm living now
in a guitar with my husband and family
and work for the college as an adult
educator I've been doing it for 10 years
now and I just love it this course is a
fur design and production first it's a
sealskin preparation the whole scene was
cut up skinned cleaned scraped stretched
although the whole process of seal skins
was done first three weeks and now it's
all pattern making traditional pattern
making and the traditional sewing
techniques to see last one right now a
lot of our students are sewing their
skins and preparing for the chemists not
a lot of us have learned the techniques
in these styles to make comics at home
because we're in school system now his
homework and other activities going on
in the community we have disconnected
with our mothers way of doing their
skinny
the relationship here is awesome like
everyone here speaks our language our
mother tongue in attitude and we
encourage it so much especially when
we're doing the practical sewing our
instructor is an elder respected elder
and when she talks it's commonly her
language morning living upon the boards
we have terminology glossary lift we're
actually learning new words our energy
towards that we've lost along our way
forget to remember regular mokou
my name is regular I'm not pop I'm from
cricket dog I'm the instructor for for
design program that is being held here
at dirty college we started from right
from the beginning from raping the fat
off from the sealskin we should catch
them and ride them outside this is
traditional for us I've been doing this
for so many years and they're the best
for the north to wear especially in the
winter and for the guys who goes out
hunting what we're doing is wet in the
area and just coming up with the top 40
we call that tool and removing the
stained dried blood there once all that
is cleaned on both skins first thing
that we have to do is tie the end or the
edge of the whole skin and make it into
a huge like a ball type for inside skin
outside and how big is the ball gonna be
big it'll be big once it once we turn it
into a ball fight we're gonna stomp
stomp on it I'm gonna do dancing on it
whatever I stomping on skin gets this
skin part more flexible once it's easier
enough to work with we still get that
testicle to the tool and we scrape off
the dry part and make it into like a
smoother skin that because actually I
just want to say to the younger one
scene today I would like you guys to
keep the traditional clothing
alive I told you to learn because they
are the best for the north what's the
Golder the sort of dream that you have
for your students after this is over
it's basically up to each student like
Susie said that she wants to learn to
make hammock for her family after
students achieve what their short-term
goal is you never know if their goal can
become further out somewhere it's gonna
look it's not all about the skin it's
about the whole thing that's what we
were brought up that's what we're gonna
keep it here and that's how we're gonna
do it in a conference
you
you